this video is made possible by
brilliance you're gonna learn more about
brilliant later in today's video but if
you'd like to learn more about them
right now go to brilliant dot org
forward slash of bio graphics you'll
also find a link in the description
below Leonardo da Vinci was a genius who
invented revolutionary ideas centuries
before the rest of the world would catch
up with him he embodies the definition
of a Renaissance man one who studied and
mastered a variety of different subjects
he was a painter an engineer an
architect a writer a scientist and an
inventor well you may know him for his
most famous works like the Mona Lisa or
the Last Supper few people know the man
behind the paintings today on bio
graphics we're telling you all about
Leonardo da Vinci
[Music]
a baby boy named Leonardo was born on
April 15 1452 in a Tuscan village called
Vincey the child was born out of wedlock
to a wealthy legal notary named Messer
piero through CEO de
antonio and a beautiful peasant girl
named catarina de miel EP his father
took responsibility for the boy and
raised him on the family estate with his
wife but as a bastard child young
Leonardo was not even allowed to be
given his father's last name he was
simply called leonardo da vinci which
means leonardo of Vincey Leonardo lived
with his biological mother until he was
five years old when his father took over
the responsibility of raising him
Caterina went on to marry a man who was
simply referred to as the fighter
Leonardo's father Meza married a 16 year
old noble girl named Al Behrens they had
legitimate children of their own instead
of going to school the countryside was
young Leonardo's classroom even as a
young age she was inquisitive and he
truly fell in love with nature he wished
that men could fly like the birds swim
through the oceans like the fish
together with his brothers they played
games of war and he imagines being
triumphant in battle like the men in the
stories that were told by his father
however this stage of innocence it
couldn't last forever as he grew up
Leonardo learns that he would not be
allowed to inherit the family estate
further Leonardo had nine brothers and
three sisters so even if he could
inherit his father's estate it's not
like there's gonna be much to go around
so well Leonardo had to learn a trade
and figure out how to take care of
himself now in medieval Florence guilds
they were sort of like today's trade
unions and they were split up into
multiple categories of jobs that a man
could choose from so long as he was born
into the right social class the
highest-ranking guilds were called the
arty manga and his father would have
been a part of the guild for powerful
lawyers judges and notaries but as an
illegitimate child this was like being
in the lower class and he was not even
allowed to join the lesser guild
categories which middle-class workers
like blacksmiths and stonemasons were a
part of his only option was to join the
guild which held lower-class jobs like
bakers and Millers however Leonardo's
father he still wanted his son to
good life now he could see that the boy
had a natural talent for art so his
father introduced him to a man called
Andre del Verrocchio who ran an art
studio in the city of Florence after
seeing the boys sketches he agreed to
take him on as an apprentice
[Music]
Andre del Verrocchio add several artists
and craftsmen working for him in his
workshop he would take on Commission's
from the wealthy and the powerful Medici
family and divide the work amongst his
students and employees their studio
worked on improving the beauty of the
city they had to work with all mediums
whether it was carving marble statues
casting metal or painting portraits even
architecture bridges and lots of other
civil engineering projects were all
sketched by members of this guild
so this made it necessary for Leonardo
to learn multiple disciplines after a
few years of training Leonardo da Vinci
assisted Verrocchio in painting a
commissioned piece for the Catholic
Church called the baptism of Christ this
was a very large mural on the wall of a
church so there was plenty of space for
two artists to stands and work on the
painting at the same time
Rocio instructed Leonardo to paint two
angels that had been included in his
rough sketch when DaVinci was done Rocio
was in total shock he could not believe
how gorgeous and lifelike the painting
was he knew that the students had
already surpassed the master by his
mid-twenties Leonardo da Vinci became a
master artist at Verrocchio's studio and
he earned himself a reputation leonardo
conducted a lot of experiments with arts
like studying how light changed the
shading on an object or the perfect time
of day to sketch someone's face however
his talents it was also a curse because
it caused a lot of jealousy among the
art community a 24 years old
DaVinci was accused of having sex with a
male prostitute and he was arrested for
sodomy at that time the punishment for
sodomy was being burned to death but
when he went to trial no evidence was
presented and no witnesses came forward
and they simply could not prove that had
done anything illegal so they had to let
him go however even though he was found
not guilty he still wrote in his
journals that this scandal very
seriously hurt his reputation few
clients wanted to work with him in
forints despite his obvious talents now
we don't know to vincey's actual sexual
orientation we only know that he never
got married
some believe that he chose to be
celibate in order to focus on his work
at the end of the day whoever turned him
in to the authorities definitely wanted
him dead as awful as this sounds
medieval times they were truly cutthroat
and
of high standing always had to watch
their backs to make sure they were not
killed by their enemies an assassin
named Bernardo de been Dino Baron
Shelley stabbed Gianna de Medici in the
streets simply because they were both
from rival banking families one of
Leonardo's earliest known sketches was
his observation of Baron Shelley's body
and the gallows and it was titled
the hanged man after this dispute
between the Baron Shelley's and the
Medici families forints and naples they
were on the brink of war the men in de
vince these girls they were forced to
stop working on art and to use their
engineering skills to defend the city
since de Vincey was a bastard he could
not become the knight and serve in the
royal court instead he started to design
ladders and massive weapons to help
defend forints should they ever need it
perhaps he saw this as his way to be
remembered in the history books
during a three month time period the
city was on edge believing they were on
the brink of war when Lorenzo Medici
returns after making a successful peace
treaty the rest of the city celebrated
but Leonardo he was actually
disappointed after peace returns in the
city the artists guild could go back to
making beautiful things but this was no
longer challenging or interesting to the
Vincey when he was 29 years old he was
asked to do his first commissioned mural
at a church all by himself
the painting was called adoration of the
Magi and he took his concept above and
beyond what any other painter had done
previously it was an incredible piece
but da Vinci didn't seem to see that
because after spending a very long time
working on the piece he decided that he
simply could not finish the painting he
was very restless at that time and he
didn't have the patience to actually sit
and complete a lot of his projects he
had so many brilliant ideas but he
sometimes had trouble executing on them
da Vinci was actually sued more than
once for getting paid by a patron that
then failing to finish the work as he
promised this coupled with the
accusation of sodomy meant that his
talents was simply not enough to make up
for his bad reputation
he thought that now maybe it was the
time to start over somewhere new now
just before we get into da Vinci's new
stage of life I do want to quickly tell
you about brilliance now I can't promise
you that they'll turn into the next
DaVinci but I can promise you that
brilliant will improve your
understanding of what he and other great
scientists have done brilliant are a
science learning platform that allow you
to learn through something called active
learning which sums up is basically the
opposite of that feeling of reading a
really complex paragraph about some
principle and then having no idea what
on earth they're talking about even if
you've read it a dozen times and it's
not just the basics that brilliant cover
although they totally cover the basics
as well they go all the way through to
things like complex statistics and a
whole lot else whether you want to like
da Vinci look at some classical
mechanics or maybe he wants to jump
ahead just a few years and look at
special relativity or quantum objects
brilliant makes even the most complex
concepts easy to understand they give
you something super short to read it's
just a few lines it's very easy to get
through and then you immediately apply
what you just learned to a problem you
simply rinse and repeat that and
suddenly you're understanding a whole
bunch of stuff that you didn't think it
would be I've been using brilliant and I
think you should go try it out just to
see how fascinated is for such a complex
subject to be so easily grasped you can
support bio graphics by going to
brilliant dot org forward slash by
graphics and let's get back to different
see
[Music]
even though he was more talented than
many of the other painters in Florence
Leonardo da Vinci still went through a
midlife crisis when he was 30 years old
he realized that the lifestyle of a
professional artist it did not suit him
and he craved the adventure of having a
career in weapon design he had an entire
book filled with incredible inventions
that would not be made until years later
this included things like a tank a giant
crossbow underwater scuba gear and even
a robotic soldier he was truly hundreds
of years ahead of his time but without a
war these weapons they never actually
came to life Leonardo da Vinci he
planned to move to Milan the most
northern Italian state was he also
wanted to secure employment before he
made that journey so we know why he
wanted to leave Florence but why did he
choose Milan well that's because the
city was much closer to France so they
were far more interested in gathering
weapons to defend the country da Vinci
sent a letter to the Duke of Milan
claiming that he was a weapon design
expert and he included a few pages from
his sketchbook at the very end of the
letter he also included the single-line
mentioning that he was also a painter
this letter went to Ludovico Sforza the
temporary Duke of Milan he was holding
this position of power until his nephew
came of age the supportive family had
not been in power for very long
especially compared to the likes of the
Medicis support sir invited Leonardo da
Vinci to visit and he was overjoyed
hoping that he would finally be able to
make that career change that he wanted
but once he got there he was gravely
disappointed to find out that the Duke
wanted him to paint a portrait of his
beautiful mistress today that portrait
is called lady with an ermine even
though he came to Milan to escape being
a painter he still blew people away with
his talent so also was so impressed that
he commissioned a statue of a 24 foot
tall horse da Vinci told him that it
would take at least three years to
complete
in reality though da Vinci was stalling
for time because without the help of his
old master studio he had no idea how
he's gonna pull off a 20 foot tall metal
cast horse the supposes they were
establishing themselves and the duke of
milan believed that paying for things
like metal statues would somehow prove
permanence in high society at first
DaVinci created the horse out of clay
and it was unveiled at a party it
suppressed them so much that da Vinci
was accepted into the Sforza royal court
unfortunately like a lot of his projects
da Vinci was in a bit over his head and
he was running out of time by a stroke
of luck so also decided to go to war and
he needed the metal resources for his
armies weapons once again Leonardo da
Vinci thought that this this might be
the time that he can shine with his
weapons but there were not enough
resources to pay for their creation the
Duke of Milan gave him a new assignment
in decorating a church called Santa
Maria delle grazie Oh which is where he
painted one of his most famous works the
Last Supper at the time the priests were
actually very annoyed with him because
it took him over three years to complete
the painting for the next 17 years da
Vinci enjoyed a life of financial
security and respect in forces royal
court during the time that he lived in
Milan da Vinci at a secret project that
he never dared to tell anyone
he was dissecting human cadavers and
sketching their bodies muscles and
organs
he also made wax casts of the organs now
this all sounds rather creepy and
DaVinci knew this which is why he kept
this sketchbook a secret and it only
showed up in the 1600s at that time
autopsies and any other form of
disturbing the dead was frowned upon by
the Catholic Church he already knew what
it was like to have a solid reputation
back in Florence so he was far more
careful this time essentially leading a
double life even though his sketchbook
was found over a hundred years later his
studies of the human body
they were revolutionary and became the
foundation of modern Anatomy Leonardo da
Vinci would write in notebooks about his
scientific experiments his inventions
and artistic ideas there are over 15,000
pages of his notes that have survived
even wrote some of those notes backwards
so you could only read them when looking
in a mirror some people believe that he
did this because he was worried that
people would steal his ideas
[Music]
when Leonardo DaVinci was 50 years old
the Sforza family lost their position of
power in the French invaded Milan when
they saw the giant clay horse statue
standing on the estates they used a
target practice leonardo davinci he had
to leave Milan with the bare necessities
including his journals but he left all
of his works of art behind he decided to
travel from place to place once again
trying to pitch his ideas for military
weaponry around Italy he showed the Duke
of Venice his ideas which included a
snorkeling suit for breathing underwater
that actually worked he had ideas on how
humans could fly or walk on the bottom
of the ocean keep in mind this was at a
time when people didn't even have clocks
or watches to tell time while all of his
ideas were amazing they were far too
ahead of its time and the Duke of Venice
didn't find any need for these
inventions de Vincey he was forced to
reluctantly move back to Florence and he
was reluctant because he fear that
everyone would still remember his bad
reputation but it was actually far worse
than that by that time the people had
forgotten all about the name Leonardo da
Vinci and there was a new genius in town
Michelangelo and he was just 26 years
old since the art world in Florence was
so competitive Leonardo hated
Michelangelo almost immediately da Vinci
was clearly jealous and had to find
reasons to dislike Michelangelo he would
write angrily in his journal about how
he thought the young man was dirty and
undignified despite the long beard you
see in most depictions of da Vinci he
actually spent all of his younger years
making sure that he was always
clean-shaven and he always wore the
finest of clothes he even had
professional musicians playing music for
his clients while they sat for their
portraits and the whole process it was
sort of like going to a luxury spa
Michelangelo on the other hand he had
the polar opposite approach to his art
he was so focused on his work that he
would forget to shave for days and that
his beard grow out he let ships of stone
and dust cover his home after working on
a statue and it was far more like a
workshop than a comfortable place for
clients to stay the two artists they
deeply disliked each other and even once
got into a fight in public secretly da
Vinci would go home to write about how
depressed he was to be getting older as
well as writing about the fear and
anxiety that ruled his
[Music]
since da Vinci could no longer secure
his place in the Florence art scene he
decided to try his luck at weapon design
one last time Pope Alexander had a
bastard son named Cesare Borgia some
people say that he was a great leader
while others say the bore Joe was a
bloodthirsty ruler who killed as anyone
he got in his way
Machiavelli's famous burka called the
prince was even based on border as an
example of what a ruler must do in order
to stand power the Vincey sent his
sketches to border and finally hear
someone saying yes to his weapons he
became chief general engineer for border
and supervised the construction of
towers weapons and bird's-eye view maps
of the cities which she plans on
invading which was revolutionary for the
time to Vincey got everything that he
wanted but it was at a price he never
expected the only reason why Borgia was
willing to pay for the creation of all
these weapons was because he wanted to
kill as many enemies as possible until
this point the idea of war had simply
been just a concept to Leonardo da Vinci
and stories of knights going into battle
it seemed like fun for the first time in
his life da Vinci actually witnessed
what a bloodthirsty battle looked like
and it was too gruesome for him to
handle
he wrote truly man is more savage than
beasts for our brutality exceeds theirs
we live by the death of others the straw
that broke the camel's back was when
Borgia ordered the death of one of da
Vinci's close friends he quietly left
border in the dead of the night and
moved back to Florence where he returns
to a peaceful life painting portraits
[Music]
after selling those weapons leonardo de
Vence II had saved a nice nest egg for
his retirement and it was during this
time that he painted the Mona Lisa no
one knows for sure who she actually is
there are several theories but none have
been confirmed unlike all those
portraits that were commissions and
given away he carried the portrait of
Mona Lisa with him for the rest of his
life for once this was a piece of art
that was done just for him but he was
constantly changing it because he never
felt he got it exactly right during his
retirement he started to build massive
wings for human buildings in the hopes
that one day people would fly he said
there will be wings for man if it is not
accomplished by me it will be
accomplished someday by some other there
is a commonly told story that during a
flight attempt with these wings someone
fell and broke their leg after this
failed attempt II designed a motor that
would flap the wings but it never worked
properly however he did eventually
design the first wing that looks very
much like what we use in modern day
airplanes
besides the patrons that he served
Leonardo da Vinci was not yet famous
around the world he intended to publish
in books but he never actually went
through with it as we mentioned earlier
he wrote and sketched over 15,000 pages
on a variety of subjects but he was a
perfectionist so he continued to add
more and more information because he
never felt that his work was complete
among these notes are multiple sketches
of an old man with a beard we all
assumed that this was his self-portrait
but no one knows for sure
however this image is used to portray
him in popular culture and it's how he's
remembered today now King Francis the
first of France had been collecting da
Vinci's pieces for years since he wrote
a letter to da Vinci inviting him to
live in his chateau de vincennes to
France and when he was 65 years old he
had a stroke which paralyzed his arm the
king's castle became his comfortable
retirement place and he was given the
very best medical care that money could
buy when he died in the year 1519 he
left the Mona Lisa and all of his sketch
books and journals to his loyal
apprentice Bona bastard Leonardo da
Vinci died like a king his life lives on
forever in his work and he will continue
to serve as an inspiration to people
around the world for
centuries to come so really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do give us a thumbs up below and
don't forget to subscribe we've got
brand new videos several times a week so
hit that subscribe button and you will
be notified when those come out and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]
you